hi welcome to my talk thanks for showing
up also hi to the remote attendees
um to get us started and because I'm
actually really curious I would like to
ask who of you is currently using a
Transformer model in production
fans
who is currently in the face of trying
it out like experimenting a bit if it
works for your use case
who hasn't tried it out yet and is here
to learn a bit about the topic
okay quite quite equally distributed I
would say that's nice
so I hope you you will all get something
out of this talk
um
so for the last years
um I had an impression everyone in the
internet is trying to tell me that got
an NLP problem nowadays use Transformers
just download a pre-trained model from
the app
and let me start by saying that's not
bad advice
despite everything you were here in the
next 25 minutes I would still recommend
you the same
um but my personal transition from
training recurring neural networks from
scratch to fine-tuning pre-trained
Transformer models has not been
straightforward
uh to give you some context I'm a deep
learning engineer at omnius and we
automate claim handling that means I'm
working with documents you would send to
your insurance in case you break your
car or you manage to set your flat
underwater
and I realized quite early on that these
documents were too long to work with all
these internet tutorials out of the box
and figuring out what are the underlying
reasons for that and how to Circle them
circumvent them took me a lot of time
time reading papers searching
documentation digging into code and I
hope this talk will be a nice summary of
what I learned over the last years and
it will help you get started faster if
you are in the same situation and have
to work with long input sequences
so my documents being too long means
usually longer than 512 tokens that is
the limit that really many of the
pre-trained Transformer models have
so my first question was how much text
can I actually fit into 512 tokens
so what is the token
um anything essentially between a
forward and a single character the
important part is that it is part of the
Transformers vocabulary
so the vocabulary you can see here on
the left so it's a set of common words
like invoice common sub words like
gmail.com and all of the characters you
might find in your texts
um and every entry in the vocabulary is
mapped to a vector representation that
gets learned during training
so now if I want to use a Transformer on
let's say my text my invoice I take the
text invoice 417 and the first step is
to tokenize it so since invoice is quite
a common word it would become a single
token most likely but the invoice number
517 it's an arbitrary number so it would
not be part of the vocabulary that's why
it gets split into multiple tokens in
this case most likely down to the
Character level like split into single
characters
um
now that every token is part of the
vocabulary we can go back to this
embedding Matrix and pick the vector for
each token and this is what then gets
um fit into the Transformer model at the
end you will get out a feature
representation for every total
so in this particular example we started
with two words of text invoice 417
and we got four tokens out of it
so how does this token to word ratio
look in general
for that you have to know that the
vocabulary depends on the pre-training
Corpus so it is selected to
selected to represent the retaining cop
as well so the words on top words that
are common in your pre-training Corpus
will make it into the vocabulary
so now if you take this pre-trained
model with its fixed vocabulary and
apply it on your data the token to word
ratio depends on multiple factors so one
of them is how similar is your data to
the pre-training Corpus so if you're
applying the model on same language same
domain you will get a pretty low tone to
word ratio
what also matters is the frequency of
rare words so as I showed you in the
example invoice numbers are never part
of the vocabulary I bonds are never part
of the vocabulary same for phone numbers
email addresses rare last name so if
your texts have a lot of these content
then you will end up with a lot of
tokens
um funnily enough the language itself
also matters so for English you get
along with very few tones while for
languages like Finnish Greek Tamil you
tend to get a lot of tones per word
um
so in absolute numbers if you are lucky
you can achieve something like 1.2 so
let's say you have like plain English
text and an English pre-trained model
and if you are me it's more like two to
three tokens per words rather in the
direction of three
so with a 50012 tokens limit that would
make like around 200 words of text which
you can input into your Transformer so
200 words might still be difficult to
imagine that's why
I brought you some example documents I'm
working on so these are all invoices
and the text you can see here
highlighted in yellow is what fits into
this 512 tokens so this is the maximum
most Transformer models can process
and as you can see
I cannot even fit a one-page document
and if you manage to set your flat
underwater for real I assure you you're
not going to be done with a one-page
invoice
so still my impression is the amount of
text I want to process here is not
observed so I bet that some of you will
also run into this 512 tokens limit
take away from those first part is 515
tokens might not be enough for every use
case
um so as I said I was coming from
training recurrent neural networks where
I can feed any sequence lengths I want
so why do Transformers even have a
sequence length limit
for that we need to to dig a little bit
into the architecture
so the mechanism
to figure out the relationships between
the different input tokens in a
Transformer is self-attention and
self-attention itself has no
understanding of order
to make this a little bit more tangible
if we have this text and this sequence
of input tokens we could actually swap
the order of tokens and we would still
get the same output so if we would swap
here invoice and and one
we would still get for every token the
same same output representation so
really like the transformer doesn't
understand the order of the tokens that
that go in or like self-attention in
itself doesn't understand it so we need
some way to provide information about
the position of tokens in the sequence
and one way to do this is absolute
position embeddings the mechanism here
is very similar to what we've seen
earlier for the token embeddings so the
model has an embedding Matrix which is
learned end to end and instead of the
vocabulary on the left side we have
absolute positions in the sequence and
for every position we can look up and
embedding
so if we look at the model again we now
have two inputs the token embeddings and
the position embeddings and this works
like this so for example invoice is in
the sequence at position one so I would
go back here to the metrics pick the
entry from position one
Forest at position two so I would go
back here pick the entry from position
two
so now imagine if I would have a
sequence that is longer than 512
I would get essentially an index error
if I wanted to perform this operation
absolute position embeddings is what the
early Transformers use so for example
bird and since many many papers built on
top of that it's still very common
nowadays
people also developed Alternatives
um relative position embeddings so here
the idea is a bit different
um the position information is not added
to the model as part of the input but
the idea is to modify the self-attention
mechanism
so if we go back to the example the idea
here would be
if we compute the attention between
invoice and four we would say okay the
relative distance between these tokens
is one while if we compute the attention
score between invoice and one we would
say the relative distance is two so it's
not that the token invoice always has a
fixed position embedding but it depends
on what's the pairing token to compute
the attention
um
there's different flavors of this and I
linked you here the train short test
long paper which is a really nice
comparison of
training in inference speed memory
consumption generalization to longer
sequences for these different methods
but
um the key takeaway here is that if you
have relative position embeddings there
is no total limit you can feed a
sequence as long as you want to the
Transformer
or rather as long as your GPU wants so
if you're working with long sequences
chances are quite high that you also run
into Hardware limits I don't want to go
into details here but the good news is
there's a lot of research on that on
making the tension mechanism
more efficient so the vanilla attention
has quadratic memory consumption with
respect to the input sequence length but
there's a lot of work on making this I
don't know like linear or in some way
like more efficient than project
I also linked to a very nice comparison
paper here which contains so many
methods that's actually impossible to
process that all
um
now let's have a look at the most
downloaded models from the hiring phase
hub
so in this table you can see the
different model types and which type of
position embeddings they use and if they
use some sort of efficient attention
and I think the picture is quite clear
so most models use absolute position
embeddings and I want to emphasize that
again these models cannot predict on
sequences longer longer than 512 tokens
as we've seen before this is like half a
page of document
um
so funnily enough I want to highlight
the entry for layout M here
so layout m is a Transformer that was
designed for working on documents so it
was designed for use cases like mine and
it still has this 512 tokens limit
so and for me the slide also shows the
big problem of this pre-training and
fine-tuning parroting so it's not enough
that techniques like relative position
embeddings are invented but the people
who open source the pre-trained models
also have to adopt them it doesn't help
that I now have the theoretical
knowledge how to like do this better I
don't have the resources to create my
own pre-trained model
so
um yeah the takeaway here is that most
models are limited to 512 tokens
but for a very long time I was wondering
like I can't be the only one with
sequences longer than 512 tones don't
people at least occasionally encounter
these longer sequences so what do they
do then if the models have absolute
position embeddings
so my first idea was to go and look at
the paper who developed the models
um
so you know how the abstracts read
nowadays I just pasted you some examples
here new state of the art on this this
and this data set so the new models get
evaluated on so many benchmarks there
must be some examples and some of these
benchmarks that are longer than 512 no
so what I did next is look into the
details of how they applied these models
when they evaluated on those benchmarks
so what did the authors mention how they
handled these longer sequences and the
set summary is they don't mention
anything at all so also I pasted you
some examples here and they might get
very detailed like the gpt2 example here
okay we added this prompt we used this
sort of sampling strategy these
parameters then we picked up the first
three sentences okay pretty detailed or
the other example we follow common
practice s in reference to the bird
paper
and then if you go check that paper it
is actually no information about long
sequences
so that's the point where I got really
skeptical
so my next question was do our
benchmarks even have long sequences and
um by the way it was impossible to
figure out these statistics anywhere
online so I ended up downloading the
test sets of a lot of benchmarks and do
the counting myself
what I found out what I found out is
that indeed many benchmarks don't have
long sequences
when I realized that this was also true
for the benchmarks used to evaluate
document understanding like layout am I
was like what I mean this is the same
use case I have how can these documents
look like that there is no example of
more than 512 tones and I gave you one
here so I said at home thinking like I
should just ditch my car invoices I
should work on crispy choco invoices
instead my life would be so much simpler
um
well my take on this slide is that
there's plenty of benchmarks with short
sequences only and I think that's why so
many papers get away with continuing to
use absolute position embeddings and not
think about how to use them then for
predicting on longer sequences
but I also found some benchmarks which
do have longer sequences so here I
plotted you the diff the distribution of
of sequence lengths for Doc vqa race and
CNN daily mail
um
so the the red line you can see in the
plots is this 512 token limit so all the
examples that are on the right of this
red line
um cannot be processed by the models
still have read papers where they used
absolute position embeddings and
evaluated on those benchmarks and still
there was like no mention at all how
they did it
so I was wondering people just secretly
truncate their sequences
and the only ever confirmation I got for
this hypothesis was the Roberta paper so
here they say about their evaluation on
the the race Benchmark we truncate
question answer pairs that are longer
than 128 totals and if needed the
passage so that the total length is at
most 512 tones
so if we look at the distribution of
race and knowing they truncate to 512
tokens
that means they would in some cases
discard 50 of the passage the passage
that is needed to answer the question
and apparently most paper authors think
that that this is too unimportant to
even mention so I don't know I'm just
really really confused about that
so to end this block was some good news
there is progress on The Benchmark front
um a while ago long range Arena was
released that's a set of tasks
specifically designed to evaluate on
Long sequences and there's a public
leaderboard comparing different model
architectures
um I think it's great that we have this
Benchmark and I've seen people use it
but my impression is that there's like
people working on long range Arena on
the one hand side and then there's the
the other people working on the short
benchmarks and my impression is that
these communities are still like pretty
separated
okay
so here we are like we have a lot of
great models that unfortunately don't
work on Long sequences so what can we do
in practice
um
I would say my first recommendation is
to be smart in your choice of model
so if you have long sequences and you
want to avoid a fixed token limit for
example 512
I recommend you to use moddeds with
relative position embeddings example
architectures for that T5 Transformer XL
XL net and Bloom
if that doesn't work and you do use a
model with absolute position embeddings
then you can pay attention that at least
it supports a large number of
position embeddings to be honest there's
not too many of those but big birds for
example supports more than 4 000 tokens
which should be enough for plenty of use
cases
um the other limitation like the GPU
memory limitation
um for that I would I would recommend
you to use models with efficient
attention examples for that long T5 Big
Bird long former reformer and many more
um the nice part about long T5 and big
bird is that they kind of help you on
both fronts with the token limit and
with the GPU limit
um if you're not just using a
pre-trained model but also fine-tuning
it on your data and GPU memory is a
concern for you then I recommend you to
learn about techniques to reduce this
memory footprint during training for
that I linked you a very nice overview
um by hugging face here
of course if you want to pay attention
to
um yeah choosing choosing models was
relative position embeddings and all
that
you're a bit Limited in your choice of
of models so
on the very top here you can see like
the whole hacking face Hub has more than
100 000 models to choose from
if you limit it to let's say T5 because
you want t5's relative position
embeddings then you can still choose
from 5000 models and then if on top you
also want
um the efficient attention that would
make it long T5
and then well you're down to
83 models you can choose from and then
it becomes more likely that you can't
find the model for your language your
domain fine on your task and in the size
you were actually looking for
so choice of model would be my first
advice if here you can't really solve
the problem
but you're fine-tuning on your own
documents and then there's something you
can do about the token limit for
absolute position embeddings
and which is
you can resize the position embeddings
metrics so you can add more entries as
you can see here on the bottom so we
just add a new entry for absolute
position 513 and 514.
and these these vectors are initialized
randomly so you need to fine tune on
Long sequences to update these vectors
so that over time they become as
meaningful as the initial 512.
code wise that's really easy so there's
nice convenience functions to to do that
I never tried it myself so I can't tell
you if these representation will ever
get as good as the initial 500.
if that's also not really an option for
you then you can see if you just take a
problem at prediction time so it has
different ways you can use these models
with total limits during prediction so
as we've seen from the papers one option
is to just truncate your input sequences
to the allowed limit
that's very easy to do and quite fast
and I'll link to here paper which
evaluates different approaches for long
document classification and they find
that truncating is actually still pretty
competitive so I would recommend you to
check your your sequence lengths like if
you are just a little bit over the token
limit or not not for too many of your
your of your examples at all then this
might be the perfect approach for you
that's not for you what you can do is
take your long input sequence split it
into multiple shorter chunks predict on
every chunk and try to combine the
results
this combination of results will look
differently for every task
um and maybe it's really hard to do for
some
I guess the easiest would be
if you're working on named entity
recognition for example or translation
then okay you have multiple chunks you
produce the sequence of output tags or
translated sentences and then you just
concatenate them that should be fine for
summarization at least theoretically you
can do the same so generate a summary
for each paragraph separately and then
concatenate the results I'm a bit
skeptical though if you wouldn't get any
duplicate content in there in the output
if we move on to classification also
very common task
here you would have the situation that
you get a different distribution of
classes for every chunk so
what you could do is try to average
those and then pick the class with the
highest probability
or you could try to somehow stack
another layer on top two I don't know
learn end to end how to combine these
multiple chunk predictions into a single
prediction in the end
um
another popular task
is extractive question answering so I
guess here the challenge is that in
order to extract the question uh sorry
to extract the answer
it it needs to be fully contained in one
of the chunks you predict on so you
probably need to use overlapping chunks
to make sure that the answer is at least
fully contained in one of them and then
you can have a look at the confidence of
your predictions and and pick the one
with the highest confidence
but also I don't have to tell you that
this is quite compute intensive so yeah
mediocre workarounds that's how I I
titled the section I think
um another approach for the question
answering problem could be some sort of
two-stage procedure so that you
for example using heuristics select a
short paragraph that is relevant first
and then you apply your question
answering Transformer on top of that
so I think that's all the ideas I had on
the topic so just to summarize the last
25 minutes
um 512 tokens is too little for some use
cases
the token limit is caused by absolute
position embeddings
if you work on Long sequences you should
choose your model wisely I recommend you
to use long T5 or Big Bird
and if model Choice doesn't solve your
problem then you can apply different
prediction strategies like truncating or
predicting on chunks
I will make the slides available so if
you wanna
look through them again or follow up any
of the links then you can check them out
at speaker deck and I think we will also
distribute the content of various talks
in the Discord
so then my last slide is this one I
think I got the perfect spot actually
the the perfect time slot so I'm really
curious to hear about your experiences
using Transformers what worked for you
what didn't work for you if you ran into
the same issues or of course if I'm
overlooking something obvious here so I
would just like to invite you for for
everyone who wants to chat about
Transformers over lunch to just gather
here in the corner like stay here after
the car so we can continue the the
conversation over lunch that would be
great
[Applause]
thank you Marianne great talk talking
through about long sentences a tough
game
is there some question here
yes
oh yeah
thanks so I vaguely remember that
positional encodings are created by
using the sine function to encode the
positions I'm just not remembering why
you wouldn't do this by
do this on the fly like why why is it
needed that it I mean faster lookup for
sure but why why wouldn't just the the
models use like on the Fly positional
encoding do you have any clue why that
is
um let's maybe look back so I mean
you're right I kind of skipped this part
so the
very early Transformers instead of using
a learned absolute position embeddings
as here
what is happening
um instead of using learned absolute
position embeddings like here they use
some uh sinusoidal like computed
embeddings and for that it's true you
could actually extend it
under yeah like there's no limits in
that sense so you could go go on and
compute these these embeddings for like
higher positions than 512.
um
but so I I linked here this paper train
short uh test long which also compared
these uh sinus order or however they're
called embeddings
and the truth is it doesn't crash but it
generalizes very badly to longer
sequence so you can use it but the
performance will be bad
thank you another question
you tell your question I will rephrase
it
so you mean that I'm sorry yeah uh so
the question is a bit difficult for me
okay okay then then let me try to repeat
it so the question was if you have
relative position embeddings
um that there then there's no explicit
limit anymore but if you don't have like
an implicit limit because the model
during training has never seen like very
a large relative distances is that what
you mean
let me try to answer I'm not sure if it
will answer your question so
um
the idea for the for the relative
position embeddings is usually that you
have
um specific embeddings for for specific
distances so you have an embedding for
distance of one two three four five and
at a certain point that just gets
truncated so at a certain point your
embedding will be
100 totals of distance or longer because
the assumption is that if it's more than
100 tokens of relative distance it's
just far away
so in that sense I'm not sure
if this is really a limitation and
practice it does this answer your
question
yeah
cool okay we have some time for our last
question
so we need some sort of position
information
because otherwise it would just look
like a back of words to the model right
this is this is what I try to show here
so if you don't insert position
information anywhere
then then the model wouldn't understand
that the sequence has some sort of order
but then how you insert the position
information there you can go for
absolute or relative
so if you don't have position
information
it just looks like a like a collection
of words like the model won't be able to
process like the sequence the words and
sequence
that's true
yeah um I'm not sure if I fully heard it
like did you say wouldn't it be better
to to use like a back of words method
instead of encoding the order
yes for some use cases that might be the
case definitely
um but I guess there's other use cases
where the order is actually important
yeah that you need to check on your use
case
thank you Marianne thank you around
let's talk